do you need information about how to go
to court or how to find a lawyer in one
of the 27 member states of the EU are
you a lawyer a notary our judge and need
to get in contact with colleagues around
Europe the e Justice portal is the
answer for your need go to e Justice
start you ropa de you and choose the
portal in your own language in the menu
on the left side of the portal you have
the entrance to an unlimited amount of
information for legal practitioners the
portal has information on case law it
tells you how to serve judicial
documents and helps you with tools for
dealing with cross-border cases such as
video conferencing find out how the
judicial system works in Estonia our how
to bring a case to court in Austria if
you need to get a divorce or have
questions regarding custody consult the
family matters section have you been a
victim of a crime the e Justice portal
offers you information about how to
apply for compensation the e Justice
portal also has information about what
to do if you received an inheritance
from another member state if you want to
resolve a dispute by mediation instead
of going to court each of this portal is
the easiest way to find information
about both different national legal
systems and also about cross-border
justice we are constantly improving our
site so you can access the information
you want as easily as possible go to our
website and try us out